Ihre themenvorschläge wie whatsapp sind einfach super auch das folgende video gibt es auf ihre anregung hin und zwar geht es um die rodung des
hambacher forst ein wald in nordrhein westfalen mittlerweile das symbol des widerstands der anti kohle kraft bewegung
gegen die zerstörung der umwelt durch die kohleindustrie doch worum geht es wirklich wer hat recht und wie wichtig ist
braunkohle für unsere stromversorgung die wichtigsten fakten zu diesem ultra wichtigen thema jetzt bei klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Wir wollen dabei sein könnt erfahrt ihr am ende des videos die bilder sind wirklich hoch dramatisch
mit mehr als 2000 polizisten die den hambacher forst räumen sollen handelt es sich um einen der größten polizeieinsätze
überhaupt in der geschichte von nordrhein westfalen am donnerstag 13 september
2018 ging es los mit dabei feuerwehr sprengstoff
expertinnen und experten und spezialeinheiten schließlich laufen die einsätze in großer höhe von bis zu
29 metern ab hier kann jeder handgriff ein leben kosten konkret geht es darum 120 vielleicht 150 aktivisten und aktivistinnen
aus ihren rund 50 baum äußern soll doch es sind lange nicht mehr nur noch diejenigen
aktivisten und aktivistinnen die sich schon seit langer zeit für den alten wahl zwischen köln und aachen einsetzen auch andere
demonstrantinnen und demonstranten haben sich auf den weg in die region gemacht dabei mussten die umwelt
aktivisten und aktivistinnen in der letzten zeit eine juristische niederlage
nach der anderen einstecken in einem eilverfahren hatte das verwaltungsgericht köln am donnerstag die beschwerde gegen die räumung durch die stadtgärten
zurückgewiesen auch das oberverwaltungsgericht münster hatte dann den stopp der räumung abgelehnt es fehle an baugenehmigungen und
brandschutz für die baumhäuser nach angaben von rwe sei es noch in diesem jahr dringend nötig den hambacher forst
roten denn nur dann könne man die kohleförderung und den
tagebaubetrieb in den kommenden zwei jahren
aufrecht erhalten ohne die rodung
drohe das erliegen der förderung und das würde rwe teuer zu stehen kommen es geht also um eine menge geld denn die kohleverstromung
macht analysen zufolge etwa 70 prozent oder mehr der stromerzeugung von rwe aus vor etwa 40 jahren
wurde der tagebau erschlossen und das rheinische revier
in dem das areal liegt gilt als größtes geschlossenes
braunkohlevorkommen in europa
38 millionen tonnen braunkohle wurden alleine im vergangenen jahr gefördert damit wurden 15 prozent des strombedarfs von
nordrhein-westfalen gedeckt dabei ist von dem ursprünglichen bald schon beinahe komplett alles von der bildfläche verschwunden
4100 hektar groß war er mal vor beginn der kohleförderung
3900 hektar sind bereits gerodet worden jetzt sollen eben auch noch die verbliebene
200 hektar wald auf weniger als 100 hektar abgeholzt werden auf die gefahr hin dass auch das image des unternehmens
leidet doch das scheint es jetzt wohl wert zu sein das resultat daraus dass sowohl eon
als auch rwe sich lange zeit nicht auf die aktuelle entwicklung wie die energiewende und den atomausstieg
vorbereitet hatten seine ökostromtochter innogy
hatte rwe erst vor zwei jahren an die börse gebracht so will man langfristig
dann wohl auch auf kohle verzichten bis dahin aber noch die profite mitnehmen die der hambacher forst in form seiner
braunkohle so bietet um das übrig gebliebene waldstück herum zum pagan sei technisch keine option so rwe und so hat sich der konzern auch
gegen das ziel der kohle kommission gestellt zusammengesetzt aus verschiedenen vertretern und vertreterinnen
der bereiche politik umweltschutz und industrie im auftrag der bundesregierung
sollte für den herbst ein konzept vorgestellt werden wie man gemeinsam den
ausstieg aus der kohle schaffen könnte das starre vorgehen von rwe in diesem zusammenhang sehen so nicht nur die umwelt
aktivisten und aktivistinnen kritisch sondern beispielsweise auch
wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin wie etwa die energie expertin claudia kemfert vom deutschen institut für wirtschaftsforschung in einem interview mit dem deutschlandfunk
wir können sehr viel schneller aus der kohle aussteigen als manche jetzt sagen und je schneller wir das tun desto weniger
muss man auch in hambach roden und braunkohle abbauen
insofern wäre es schon ratsam gewesen
man würde die diskussion der kohle kommission abwarten und dann erst zur tat schreiten wir haben ja hier darüber berichtet laut einer
fraunhofer studie ist der frühere ausstieg aus der kohle ohne probleme möglich
den link gibt es am ende des videos und in der video beschreibung zurück zur kohle kommission denn eventuell hätte die kommission ja entschieden
dass der tagebau gar nicht mehr abgebaut werden muss darauf hatten die umweltschützer und schütze rinn gehofft unter anderem der bnd
der noch im april diesen jahres
geklagt hatte schließlich seien die kriterien eines europäischen
naturschutzgebietes gegeben doch gerichte haben entschieden und so ist der innenminister von nordrhein westfalen davon überzeugt das zitat
sich der staat durchsetzen
muss schließlich sei akute brandgefahr
gegeben ja das ist jetzt plötzlich so wichtig dabei gibt es die baumhäuser im hambacher forst in denen sich die aktivisten und aktivistinnen
verschanzen schon
jahrelang sie rufen der polizei entgegen wenn ihr kinder habt dann lass den unsinn
eine klare botschaft denn längst ist der kampf gegen die braunkohle auch zu einem kampf um die zukunft unseres planeten
geworden denn die braunkohle gilt als der schmutzigste energieträger
überhaupt im vergleich zur erdgas beispielsweise hat braunkohle einen rund 60 prozent höheren ausstoß von co2
zur folge schon deswegen fordern viele umweltverbände den sofortigen ausstieg denn wie will man sonst den pariser
klimavertrag und die ziele der eu erreichen bis 2030 soll der co2 ausstoß
demnach um 40 prozent gesenkt werden im vergleich zum jahr
1990 der ausstieg aus der braunkohle ist zwar politisch
als teil der energiewende beschlossen
doch der
konkrete zeitpunkt noch nicht und trotz ihrer ganzen nachteile hat sie als energieträger kaum an bedeutung verloren die zahl der
beschäftigten im braunkohleabbau ist trotz des beschlossenen ausstiegs den letzten jahren konstant gestiegen und auch der verbrauch ist im vergleich zu anderen
auslaufenden energieträgern kaum zurückgegangen zwischen 2005 und 2007 von
54,5 auf
51 5 millionen tonnen heißt also auch nach der energiewende
hat die braunkohle eine große bedeutung für einen energiemix
und so ist der ausstieg alles andere als effektiv im gange ganz im gegensatz zu dem ausstieg aus der kernkraft und der steinkohle das problem
sowohl die beschäftigten
als auch die unternehmen leisten wie der stand und aus der politik gibt es offene unterstützer was damit bei meist übersehen wird ist die tatsache
dass braunkohle längst nicht die günstige energie ist für die sie oft gehalten wird laut einer studie des umweltbundesamtes
also des
umweltbundesamtes staatliche institutionen sind nämlich die gesellschaftlichen kosten bei der stromerzeugung aus stein oder
braunkohle besonders hoch 2016 sind dadurch gesellschaftliche mehrkosten von rund 46 milliarden euro entstanden und zwar konkret
durch umweltkosten durch luftschadstoffe wie feinstaub oder schwefeldioxid
oder eben durch das klimagas co2 diese kosten sind eben kaum
offensichtlich denn unsere gesellschaft bekommt sie nicht über die stromrechnung zu spüren finanziert wird das ganze an anderer stelle nämlich durch höhere beiträge
für steuern oder
krankenkassen beispielsweise die umweltbehörde rechnet vor dass ein geordneter kohleausstieg somit
milliarden einsparen würde und nicht nur dass strom aus wind oder solarenergie seitdem nach schon heute deutlich
günstiger drei mal günstiger als strom aus kohle
dazu der energieexperten oliver krischer von den grünen fraktion im bundestag in einem
interview mit der deutschen welle die folgen des co2 ausstoßes für die klimakrise die
gesundheitsschäden durch quecksilber feinstaub und stickoxiden die umweltschäden durch das abholzen von wäldern und das abpumpen von grundwasser
sowie die kosten kaputte häuser und straßen durch bergschäden werden einfach auf die allgemeinheit abgewälzt und
tauchen in der kostenbilanz des braunkohle stroms nicht auf nur deshalb ist braunkohle strom an der börse
billig die zeche
zahlen gerne und damit zurück zum hambacher forst er war lange zeit einer der größten mischwälder europas und hatte trotz seiner
wirtschaftlichen nutzung ein
einzigartiges ökosystem zu bieten außerdem hat er eine mehrere jahrtausend alte geschichte denn es gibt ihnen seit der jüngsten eiszeit vor
12.000 jahren das alles lässt sich nicht mehr zurückholen
und fest steht auch im oktober darf rwe dann offiziell mit der rodung beginnen wir machen hier etwas mit etwas positivem
weiter ihr könnt klicks um werbefrei machen wir haben ja schon angefangen immer mehr videos sind werbefrei dank eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung vor allem video habt werdet also mitglied hier unter dem video
draufklicken und ihr bekommt noch exklusive extra videos live streams und noch ein paar weitere privilegien für einen kleinen beitrag wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollen dann endet mich übrigens bei whatsapp da könnte auch themenvorschläge
machen dann bekommt ihr den link übrigens zum video vor allen andern von mir persönlich auf euer handy
einfach hier draufklicken und da drunter geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken mit dem
thema so kann deutschland seine klimaziele doch noch erreichen bis dann
bleibt dran